[Applauso]
dicembre 2015 sono in viaggio in
indonesia da sola sto girando con il mio
scooter da una spiaggia all'altra
ad un certo punto cielo nero comincia a
piovere in modo impressionante e io mi
trovo nel bel mezzo di un acquazzone
tropicale per chi mi conosce sa
benissimo che non ho un grande senso
dell'orientamento quindi ovviamente in
quella condizione mi perdo tiro fuori il
mio telefono
apro google maps e comincia a cercare
dove sono insomma come farà tornare alla
mia guest house arriva il primo incrocio
secondo incrocio tiro fuori il telefono
e controllo la strada
l'umidità insomma è la nemica numero uno
della tecnologia quindi in breve tempo è
il mio telefono smette di funzionare
schermo nero lo rimetto nello zaino mi
arrabatta e riesco a ritornare alla mia
guest house
dopo di che lascio il telefono lì e mi
dico ma si un paio d'ore si
riprenderanno proprio tutte le classiche
tecniche e metti lo smartphone nel riso
lasciano lì al sole insomma vadano al
proprietario della mia guesthouse e
cominciò informarmi su dove potrei
andare a comprarne uno nuovo
perché insomma devo trovare il sistema
per recuperare
mi si prospetta una cosa abbastanza
improponibile nel senso di lui mi dice
ma devi prendere un autobus poi un taxi
sono cinque ore di strada una cosa
abbastanza impegnativa per cui metto via
il pensiero di comprare un nuovo
telefono ma il mio continua non
riprendersi quella è stata la prima
volta nella vita in cui ho veramente
esperito quella che poi ho scoperto
essere l'anno mo fobia ovvero l'ansia da
non avere più il telefono con se io vi
giuro mi sono sentita spogliata ansia
continuava a guardare questo schermo
nero dicevo no ma si riprende non s'è
mai visto uno smartphone che si rompa
adesso come faccio poi sono quattro
settimane in indonesia da sola non ho un
tablet non ho un computer non ho altro e
devo stare senza no ma così ogni tempo
vabbè tempo
non ha risolto nulla il mio telefono non
si è ripreso e ho veramente capito
quello che poi ho letto tempo dopo
ovvero il nostro smartphone ma viene
descritto come il nostro 79esimo organo
noi nel corpo ne abbiamo 78 e ed è
proprio come se fosse diventata un'altra
parte del nostro corpo ormai ce lo
abbiamo talmente dentro che nel momento
in cui non è più a nostra disposizione
come se ci taglia essere una mano quasi
e vi giuro che se qualcuno prima mi
avesse chiesto ma ti ritieni una persona
molto attaccata al telefono
insomma sei una dipendente da smartphone
come si dice adesso avrei detto ma io
assolutamente no cioè lo uso per fare le
mie cose
insomma per ammazzare un po il tempo
eccetera ma tutto sommato posso farne a
meno proprio non mi tocca
e invece nel momento in cui non l'ho
avuto a disposizione panico più totale
una volta tornata da dall indonesia
torno in italia e cominciò riflettere su
questa cosa sul perché avesse reagito in
modo così forte alla aver perso il
telefono in una condizione di vacanza in
cui tutto sommato veramente potevo farne
a meno non ne avevo bisogno per
questioni lavorative sono una psicologa
quindi ovviamente mi sono fatta un sacco
di trip mentali sulle mie reazioni
durante durante il viaggio rispetto
all'uso del telefono e lì mi si è aperto
un mondo
ho veramente cominciato a studiare a
capire cos'è poi il rapporto tra
tecnologie digitali e essere umano
ovviamente mi occupo molto dell'aspetto
psicologico e mentale in questo tipo di
rapporto e
quindi tutto con l'impatto che poi ha
l'uso del digitale sulle nostre capacità
cognitive e ovviamente sono qui oggi per
parlarvi di uno di questi aspetti che è
questo semplicemente l'uso che ogni
tanto facciamo dello smartphone per
ammazzare il tempo durante una coda in
attesa di qualcosa quell'uso lì è un
utilizzo che rischia di andare ad
abbassare in modo drastico le nostre
capacità di creatività ora probabilmente
lo so cosa state pensando prima di tutto
cosa sarà mai se quando sono in metro da
una scrollatina facebook mentre solo in
coda alla posta controllo 2 news non
casca l'amica il mondo tanto cos'altro
avrei da fare no in quel tempo penso
niente e secondo quello che molti mi
dicono quando parlo di questo argomento
è sì anche se fosse io non è che voglio
essere creativo nella vita pittore lo
faccio fare a qualcun altro non è roba
per me quindi anche se la mia creatività
cala tutto sommato poco importa
ovviamente sono qui oggi per smentirmi
entrambi questi questi pensieri in caso
qualcuno di voi avesse li avesse fatti
prima di tutto la noia e quindi la
condizione in cui non facciamo niente è
assolutamente fondamentale per lo
sviluppo della creatività e in secondo
luogo la creatività è una competenza che
serve a tutti
vediamole una lava una alla volta
avete presente quella condizione in cui
non c'è niente da fare
ci si sente un po come se insomma si
guarda al soffitto si lascia vagare la
propria mente non si fa nulla di
produttivo di concreto di sensato ma si
lascia pagare semplicemente la nostra
mente quel momento da cui il nostro
cervello tra enorme beneficio perché
perché prima di tutto sedimenta tutte le
informazioni precedentemente acquisite
quindi c'è una fase di riposo in cui i
pensieri e le informazioni che abbiamo
accumulato prima possono intrecciarsi
possiamo creare nuove connessioni ed è
proprio quello il momento in cui viene
fatto ecco non è continuando a riempire
il nostro cervello di concetti di
nozioni di immagini di suoni che
facciamo del bene alla nostra mente
serve anche il vuoto
in secondo luogo la creatività è una
cosa che coinvolge tutti
pensate che creare è una parola che
deriva dal sanscrito car che significa
fare e credo che tutti noi abbiamo delle
cose da fare nella vita
creatività e problemi soling sono due
aspetti strettamente collegati e tutti
abbiamo problemi da risolvere immagino
che qui in questa stanza insomma non ci
sia nessuno che non ha delle questioni
da risolvere nella propria vita che
siano di carattere personale
professionale organizzazione della
propria vita lavorativa e personale
familiare via dicendo insomma tutti noi
ne abbiamo le questioni da risolvere i
problemi ed essere creativi ci aiuta a
risolvere i nostri problemi in modo più
efficace e più sensato nel mio viaggio
in indonesia e ovviamente ho avuto ore
ed ore di grande noia di non fare nulla
di guardare il soffitto per chi di voi
fosse stata in asia probabilmente sa
anche che la concezione del tempo in
asia è completamente diversa dalla
nostra per cui aspettare un mezzo di
trasporto un pasto le chiavi di una
camera richiede molto più tempo di
quello che non richiede qui in occidente
figuriamoci a milano in più che siamo
nella patria insomma della produttività
e del fare le cose veloci no in più
insomma in tutto quella in tutto quel
tempo non avevo niente da fare
cioè
non ci avevo niente veramente da da
scrollare non avevo un telefono per far
due foto non avevo quindi mi sono
trovata ad annoiarmi molto osservare le
persone che mi passavano intorno ma fare
due chiacchiere con quello che si sedeva
accanto a me che probabilmente non avrei
assolutamente considerata se avesse
avuto uno smartphone da in mano
probabilmente e credo proprio che io
insomma ringrazio quella vacanza
ringrazio quel momento continua a
esserne profondamente riconoscente di
questa cosa che mi è capitata per caso
perché è stata l'occasione in cui ho
incubato smart break ovvero il mio
progetto su cui lavoro oggi che è il
lavoro per cui promuovono uso sano e
consapevole dello smartphone ai tempi
lavoravo nell'ambito del turismo online
e quindi era una dipendente classica
diciamo e lì è stata la condizione in
cui ho pensato ho cominciato a pensare
ma non lo so vorrei fare altro vorrei
creare un progetto mio vorrei recuperare
un po di più anche la mia laurea in
psicologia che per qualche anno ho un
attimo accantonato non ho usato in
maniera diretta
era stato proprio quel quella fase quel
momento di settimane ore e ore a non
fare nulla che mi ha permesso in qualche
modo di incubare di maturare questa idea
ovviamente il lavoro che io faccio con
smart break coinvolge tantissimo il
telefono io lo uso per lavoro tanto
tempo e quindi credo che sia un po
quella la chiave tante persone mi dicono
ma scusa ma tu vai in giro a parlare di
non usare troppo il telefono di non
essere dipendente dalla tecnologia e poi
però ti fai video con lo smartphone
pubblichi sui social condividi e dicendo
ma c'è un po un controsenso
credo che insomma il mio messaggio
sempre in questo senso è la grossa
questione è l'utilizzo che facciamo il
come usiamo la tecnologia non è tanto il
non usarla più abbiamo in mano degli
strumenti potentissimi se pensiamo che
lo smartphone che tutti noi probabimente
abbiamo in tasca oggi è molto più
potente dei computer che ha mandato
l'uomo sulla luna e noi cosa facciamo
lo utilizziamo nella maggior parte dei
casi per guardare due notifiche social
giocare ammazzare il tempo
io dico sempre un po come se avessimo
tutti quanti una ferrari nel garage e la
utilizzassimo col cambio automatico per
andare a prendere il pane alla porta
accanto c'è un po del paradossale in in
questa condizione
kevin kelly che ha un noto futurista e
fondatore di wired ci dice che secondo
lui questo è il periodo storico migliore
in cui essere nati perché ad un costo
molto basso
riusciamo ad avere strumenti molto
potenti in mano che ci permettono di
sviluppare le nostre conoscenze
connessioni relazioni progetti e via
dicendo ma kelly ci dice anche che il
futuro sarà di chi riuscirà a mantenere
vivo il proprio lato umano e questo ha
molto a che vedere con la creatività
quindi in tutto questo la fregatura dove
sta
insomma abbiamo questo strumento
potentissimo e dove ci incastriamo ci
incastriamo molto in quello che viene
definito il multitasking
sfido chiunque di voi è in me compreso
insomma non senza nulla togliere a me
stessa a non avere almeno una volta
risposto ad un messaggio mentre
camminiamo mandato una mail mentre siamo
in riunione scollate un social mentre
siamo in compagnia o comunque abbiamo
l'illusione di poter fare più cose
insieme e lo smartphone ci dà alimenta
oltretutto questa illusione perché
sembra sembra sembra che siamo più
produttivi no se rispondiamo ad una mail
mentre stiamo camminando utilizziamo i
tempi un po quella la sensazione in
realtà insomma è stato dimostrato ormai
in diverse salse tantissime ricerche via
dicendo che il multitasking non esiste
il nostro cervello semplicemente
saltella da un compito ad un compito b
creando un sovraccaricamento e un
affaticamento della nostra mente dalla
nostra energia e quindi non rendendoci
più produttivi ma semplicemente
stancandoci è un po quella la fregatura
quindi dovremmo imparare piano piano a
ritornare in qualche modo a fare una
cosa alla volta e farla bene portarla a
termine nel mio lavoro
una delle cose principali che faccio è
quella di organizzare occasioni ed
eventi per portare le persone a
staccarsi dallo smartphone
il mio obiettivo non è quello di dire a
6 dipendente dal telefono adesso sicuro
io e te lo tolgo che così almeno
guarisci assolutamente no il mio
obiettivo è semplicemente quello di
creare le condizioni per portare le
persone a riflettere un attimo
sull'utilizzo che fanno del digitale e
sul mettere consapevolezza in questa
relazione che abbiamo con degli
strumenti molto potenti ma che rischiano
anche di rubarci molto tempo e molta
energia quando non li utilizziamo in
modo consapevole
nelle occasioni che organizzo che
possono essere insomma qualche ora una
giornata un paio di giorni per chi ha un
po più arcore vuole fare le cose un po
più potenti insomma ho diversi feedback
dai dai partecipanti dalle persone e vi
voglio vi voglio dire insomma tra i
benefici principali che le persone mi
riportano in quest'occasione ve la
racconto con le parole di chi di chi ha
partecipato ecco quindi non con le mie
primo beneficio che in tanti mi che
tanti mi dicono eh mi rendo conto di
quanto è automatico il comportamento di
andare a cercare il telefono gabriele
santo pietro che è un imprenditore un
padre di due figli nella sua giornata
senza telefono mi dice ho passato
momenti durante questa giornata un po di
dopo anche di relax e sollievo ma la
cosa che mi ha stupito di più è quante
volte metteva le mani in tasca per
andare a cercarlo e sapevo benissimo di
non averlo avevo avvertito tutta la
famiglia parenti amici colleghi che non
ce l'avevo quindi non aveva un bisogno
di andare a prenderlo in mano ma mi
veniva istintivo andare a cercarlo non è
l'unico se pensiamo che in media
tocchiamo lo smartphone oltre 2.600
volte al giorno
credo che non ci sia quasi nient'altro
che facciamo con questa frequenza
insomma il comportamento che includa un
oggetto esterno ma una volta che
riusciamo a staccarci
dall'automatizzazione di questi
comportamenti
ecco che ci accorgiamo che c'è un mondo
intorno a noi osserviamo quello che sta
accadendo intorno a noi in sti siero che
è una mamma è impiegata qui di milano
nella sua giornata senza telefono mi
dice mi sono rilassata la mattina e il
pomeriggio fatto merenda con con mia
figlia è semplicemente non avevo niente
da condividere niente da postare niente
da controllare
ho guardato quello che stava accadendo
intorno a me ho passato del tempo con
mia figlia
tutto qui sembra banale ma avere il
telefono in mano ci porta a quella che
poi viene descritta come la como la
fiero swing out cioè la paura di
perdersi qualcosa
siamo molto concentrati sulla fame
controllare perché chi lo sa che magari
succeda qualcosa dall'altra parte del
mondo che io devo sapere adesso perché
se non lo so sto male cioè sembra un
bisogno compulsivo quasi certe volte ma
non c'è non ci rendiamo conto che in
realtà poi questo comportamento ci porta
a perderci il mondo fisico che abbiamo
in quel momento le relazioni che sono
intorno a noi le persone che abbiamo di
fronte
perché non possiamo fare più cose in una
volta e quindi siamo concentrati la e ci
perdiamo quello che abbiamo qua una
volta che verrò riusciamo a stare in
questo momento nel qui ed ora nelle
relazioni nei momenti che abbiamo in
quel momento molto spesso le persone mi
dicono mi sono totalmente rilassato
mi sembrava di stare in vacanza e io gli
dico costasse così poco andare in
vacanza insomma ti eviti di prenderti un
biglietto aereo ma è solo una giornata
senza telefono e
risparmi un sacco di soldi e di tempo
però è il resoconto il feedback che mi
danno in tanti
elena meli che è una giornalista del
gruppo rcs nella sua giornata senza
telefono mi dice sono state al
ristorante con un'amica e sentivo
continuamente le suonerie uguale alla
mia e ero completamente sollevata perché
non poteva essere il mio telefono quindi
ero in vacanza completamente è tornata a
casa e la figlia gli dice mamma eri
totalmente rilassata sembravi un altra
persona
la giornalista poi mi dice appunto
bastasse così poco per sembrare un'altra
persona lo rifaccio perché cambiamento
molto molto efficace e con poche
investimento no ecco quindi questi sono
un po i tre benefici principali che le
persone riportano quando si staccano
anche solo per un breve periodo di tempo
queste sono persone che hanno fatto una
giornata senza telefono non sa come me è
un viaggio di settimane o come moreno
che si abbatte un mese senza telefono e
quindi ecco è un po questo il senso
tornando al mio viaggio in indonesia
ovviamente io sono sopravvissuta sana e
salva mi sono passata da tre settimane
bellissime che mi hanno dato anche
l'opportunità di vivere il viaggio la
vacanza in modo totalmente diverso ho
conosciuto persone che non avrei mai
conosciuto sono finite in situazioni in
cui non sarei mai finita
se avessi avuto un telefono
probabilmente sarebbe stato un altro
viaggio quindi lo consiglio ecco perché
chiunque di voi voglia voglia provarci
vorrei concludere questo questo breve
intervento con un piccolo invito che mi
piacerebbe molto vi portate a casa oggi
è il mio piccolo invito a questo la
prossima volta che avete l'istinto di
mettere le mani in tasca in borsa per
cercare il telefono
provate almeno qualche volta durante la
vostra giornata fermarvi togliere le
mani dalla tasca rilassarvi un attimo
regalarvi questo momento di vuoto di noi
sa di non fare nulla di lasciar vagare
la vostra mente e godetevelo ci sono ci
sono diverse cose che possono accadere
in questo spazio in questo momento chi
lo sa che in un momento di totale
noi è vuoto che non siamo abituati a
valorizzare in realtà poi non vi venga
un'idea non osservate qualcosa nel mondo
intorno a voi
non crediate una connessione nella
vostra testa che a quel punto poi
potrete magari approfondire in un
secondo momento
prendendo in mano il vostro smartphone
ma sarà un gesto non più automatico di
cui non siete non mi rendete conto ma
sarà una cosa assolutamente consapevole
grazie
[Applauso]